37 messerstichen selbst unter der
fußsohle
wie krank ist das aus dem kinderzimmer
hat er sie hier entlang geschliffen über
den boden man hat später schleifspuren
gefunden die hier genau durch diesen
bereichen durch diese tür und dann gab
es hier damals noch eine abtrennung mit
einer kleinen luke und durch briefe luca
hat er sich selber durch gezwängt und
dann hinter sich hergezogen
mit diesem messer sticht er mehrfach auf
heike ein erhängt ihren leblosen körper
mit einem strick an einem dachbalken und
schlägt mit diesem eisenhaken erneut zu
kaum vorstellbar so findet icos vater
seine tochter später auf dem dachboden
ihres hauses
[Musik]
das hier liebe zuschauer ist heike
rimbach damals erst 19 jahre jung sie
wird ermordet auf dem dachboden ihres
elternhauses gefunden das verbrechen ist
jetzt mittlerweile 26 jahre her und noch
immer konnte kein täter gefasst werden
ja das ganze spielt in lüttgenrode einem
ort mit nicht einmal 1000 einwohnern in
sachsen-anhalt es gab einige verdächtige
unter anderem auch ihr ex-freund und
jedesmal hofften heikes eltern natürlich
auf den großen durchbruch aber niemanden
konnte die tat am ende nachgewiesen
werden trotzdem hofft die familie auch
26 jahre danach nach diesem
schrecklichen verbrechen auf aufklärung
und gerechtigkeit aber die zeit die
läuft aus einem ganz bestimmten grund
unser reporter thilo scholtyseck der den
fall von stunde eins begleitet hat der
hat mit heikes mutter gesprochen
heike rimbach
19 jahre eine fröhliche junge frau mit
träumen hoffnungen und dem wunsch nach
einem glücklichen leben
heike zwei brüder die bindung innerhalb
der familie ist eng insbesondere die
beziehung zwischen heike und ihrer
mutter ist innig und vertraut
[Musik]
die letzte erinnerung von maria rimbach
an ihre tochter
heike streichelt ihre geliebte katze am
letzten gemeinsamen abend vor ihrem tod
eine erinnerung 26 jahre nach einer tat
die bis heute ungesühnt ist denn heike
wurde erschlagen erstochen gewirkt und
schließlich stranguliert im haus ihrer
eltern schnell das haben wir in die
augen gucken ihr sagen verdammt noch mal
warum warum diese bestialische weise
[Musik]
37 messerstichen selbst unter der
fußsohle
wie krank ist das und da ist das wort
gerechtigkeit wo ist die für uns wir
kriegen bis zum lebensende keine werden
auch bild chefreporter thilo scholtyseck
sucht seit mehr als 26 jahren eine
antwort auf die frage wie konnte der
grausame mord an heike rimbach geschehen
unter dem dach ihres elternhauses und
wer ist ihr mörder wie kann es sein dass
ein junges mädchen 19 jahre alt hier im
wohnhaus ihrer eltern am otto bock und
das 26 jahre nach der tat immer noch
kein täter gefasst
[Musik]
dann kommt der entscheidende hinweis der
zum täter führt der der familie endlich
die gewissheit gibt warum ihre tochter
ermordet wurde ein ehemaliger ermittler
und seine kollegen waren kurz davor den
fall zu lösen
doch ein täter konnte bis heute nicht
verurteilt werden es wäre mir lieber
wenn ich hier stehen würde und könnte
sagen das verbrechen ist aufgeklärt aber
es ist leider nicht so
mord verjährt nicht und ich hoffe das
passiert noch
dass diese sache aufgeklärt wird
im april 1995 fängt thilo scholtyseck
als junger reporter bei der
bild-redaktion in halle an seit august
1995 berichten er und seine kollegen
über den mordfall über tatverdächtige
wendungen und gescheiterte ermittlungen
top profiler untersucht den mordfall
heikel
dachboden nord katze führte zur toten
heike
findet er heikes mörder
wenn wir immer nach jahren wieder
einsteigen beziehungsweise wenn es einen
neuen nachrichten stand gibt dann
berichtet man wieder drüber und fragt
sich trotzdem ist jetzt gibt es jetzt
eine möglichkeit da endlich mal jemanden
zu überführen
deshalb macht sich bild chefreporter
tino scholtissek erneut auf spurensuche
trifft unter anderem heikes mutter maria
rimbach in ihrem neuen zuhause
26 jahre nach der ermordung ihrer
tochter
ihr letztes poster ich weiß die busse
haben es läuft zwischen ihren sachen
war vor es kam schlimmer
es kam schlimmer
noch schwimmen ging nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
lüttgenrode am harz 1 400 seelen dorf an
der früheren innerdeutschen grenze
in dieser ehemaligen schäferei lebte die
damals 19 jährige heike rimbach zusammen
mit ihren eltern und ihren beiden
brüdern die familie ist aus dem westen
zugezogen die eltern wollen hier einen
baubetrieb aufbauen sieben jahre nach
der wende
es ist sonntag der 27 august 1995 die
familie sitzt nach dem abendessen noch
im wohnzimmer beisammen es ist kurz nach
22.30 als heike zu bett geht am nächsten
morgen verlassen alle früh das haus nur
heike kann ausschlafen die 19-jährige
macht eine ausbildung zur metzgerei
fachverkäuferin der montag ist feiertag
was dann im haus geschieht gibt bis
heute rätsel
bild chefreporter thilo scholtyseck
sucht noch einmal den ort auf an dem
heike rimbach brutal ermordet wurde
[Musik]
dass das kinderzimmer von heike rimbach
er hat sie gelebt und am
28 august 1995 ist sie hier in diesem
zimmer von ihrem mörder späteren mörder
überwältigt worden es ist auch
rekonstruiert worden dass sie hier
bereits angegriffen wurde hat sich
offensichtlich gewirkt gedrosselt und es
gab auch das hat die obduktion ergeben
wir hier drinnen bereits ein erster
schlag auf den kopf
doch hayek smh atrium geht weiter
aus dem kinderzimmer hat er sie hier
entlang geschliffen über den boden man
hat später schleifspuren gefunden die
hier genau durch diesen bereichen durch
diese tür und dann gab es hier damals
noch eine abtrennung mit einer kleinen
luke und durch luca hat er sich selber
durch gezwängt und dann hinter sich
hergezogen er wusste wenn jetzt zeige
ich sage mal ganz profanen so da weg
kommt würde er mit einer erheblichen
strafe rechnen müssen
also fast ja möglicherweise in dieser
relation
den entschluss halten musste
mit diesem messer sticht er mehrfach auf
heike ein erhängt ihren leblosen körper
mit einem strick an einem dachbalken und
schlägt mit diesem eisenhaken erneut zu
kaum vorstellbar so findet icos vater
seine tochter später auf dem dachboden
ihres hauses wie kann man damit leben
wie das funktioniert
ich könnte keine nacht mehr lauge zu
kriegen kann so schon kaum und dann mit
sowas der muss doch das vor augen haben
haben sie mal die bilder angeguckt wie
sie da hängt an dem fall haben sie
gedopt das gesehen das war
das hat man keine rolle wie die germanen
unrecht als täter vor und kann nach
hause tragen kann mich ins bett liegen
und schlafen
wie geht s was ist das für eine psyche
da kann keine psycho mehr vorhanden
seien
später stellen rechtsmediziner fest
heike ist durch massive gewalt gestorben
schläge messerstiche strangulation jede
dieser zugefügten verletzungen hätte zum
tode führen können
experten sprechen von einem sogenannten
über töten häufig eine beziehungstat
ausgelöst durch eifersucht oder kränkung
so auch im fall heike rimbach
der täter war ortskundig und er wusste
auch dass die dann später geschädigte
sich zu haus befindet das heißt er hat
er schon sehr gute kenntnisse von zeit
faktoren und fünf wirklichkeit faktoren
sowieso
wer hat heike rimbach getötet stammt der
täter wie die ermittler vermuten aus
ihrem näheren umfeld
kannte heike ihren mörder fest steht am
abend vor der tat will heike mit ihrem
neuen freund in dessau telefonieren weil
es sechs jahre nach der wende in dem
kleinen ort noch immer keinen
telefonanschluss gibt fährt heike zum
telefonieren in einen nachbarort doch
anstelle ihres freundes erreicht sie nur
dessen mutter was wollte sie ihrem neuen
freund am abend vor ihrer ermordung
erzählen war es nur sehnsucht oder doch
eine wichtige nachricht fühlte sie sich
möglicherweise von jemandem bedroht
hatte angst
schnell steht für die polizei fest der
täter muss aus dem näheren umfeld des
opfers stammen auch heikes eltern und
ihre beiden brüder die mittlerweile
nicht mehr an die öffentlichkeit wollen
geraten ins visier der ermittler da
wurde mal so in der jüngere bruder von
der haltedauer 16 als er in handschellen
abgeführt wurde die eltern waren im
verlag unter verdacht ja und dann
passierte im grunde ein jahrelang nichts
das verbrechen russe in dem sinne die
ermittlungen laufen sich im hintergrund
und als dann der erste verdächtige 2005
geschnappt wurde ein 1 1 1 kollegen ihr
kollege aus der schlachterei von von
heike rimbach da dachte man wirklich
jetzt ist es endlich soweit jetzt ist
jemand geschnappt und das ist aber
leider auch eingestellt wurden dieses
verfahren gegen den mann ausgerechnet
ein ehemaliger metzger kollege von heike
rimbach der ihr auch nachgestellt haben
soll wurde verdächtigt in bad harzburg
rund 15 kilometer von lütgenrode
entfernt eine prostituierte aus thailand
umgebracht und eine zweite schwer
verletzt zu haben
todesursache brutale schläge wie bei
heike rimbach der mann wird verhaftet
doch für eine anklage reichen die
indizien nicht
jahrelang geschieht im fall heike
rimbach nichts erst im jahr 2008 kommt
wieder bewegung in den fall
kriminalhauptkommissar gerhard biene ist
damals teil einer neu gegründeten
mordkommission 13 jahre nach der tat
öffnet er erneut die akten geht alle
spuren und hinweise noch einmal durch in
der asservatenkammer stößt er auf schuhe
sie gehören heikes ex freund andreas s
und wurde 1995 im zimmer von heike
rimbach sichergestellt
[Musik]
an mehreren dieser fasern waren
mikroskopisch kleine blutanhaftungen
festgestellt worden die bei der weiteren
untersuchung
als menschen blut und einige dieser
partikel als das blut der geschädigten
festgestellt werden konnten
forensiker des landeskriminalamtes
entdecken auf den turnschuhen von blut
umschlossene fasern die denen des seils
mit dem heike auf dem dachboden erhängt
wird
hinzu kommt kurz vor der tat trennte
sich heike von andreas s vier jahre
waren sie zusammen er kannte sich im
haus der im was auskannte heikes
lebensumstände der vermeintliche
durchbruch im jahr 2009 wird heikes ex
freund andreas s verhaftet leichteren
das kam auch reaktionen wo ist dann ließ
gott sei dank haben endlich die sache
ganz langsam leute die samen verhaftet
das heißt noch nichts ja ich habe noch
kein urteil ich hab' ich habe noch keine
anklage anfang dezember kam dann die
nachricht
es war der zweite oder dritte
haftprüfungstermin das also außer haft
entlassen
der haftrichter erkennt keinen
dringenden tatverdacht anklage wird
nicht erhoben auch weil ein bekannter
andreas es für die tatzeit ein alibi
düster frustrierend wenn man
dann sieht wie so kommt er raus wir
haben doch eigentlich
das
gemacht was
noch möglich war doch die beweise
reichen nicht denn nach der tat wurden
die beweismittel und sachgemäß gelagert
spuren möglicherweise vermischt die
fasern auf den schuhen konnten so nicht
unmittelbar dem tatgeschehen und damit
andreas s zugeordnet werden nach der
hoffnung der rückschlag der fall heike
rimbach wird zum code case
dann ist das natürlich eine sache die
immer wieder uns beschäftigt hat weil
man natürlich mit den angehörigen
gesprochen hat das hat uns natürlich
auch emotional berührt und immer wieder
bei den ermittlungsbehörden nachgefragt
wie denn der stand ist weil man
natürlich wissen will wann wird da
jemand gefasst
seit 26 jahren kämpfen maria rimbach ihr
mann und ihre beiden erwachsenen söhne
mit dem erlebten letztere haben
mittlerweile eigene familien maria
rimbach mann ist über die jahre schwer
erkrankt kann das haus nicht mehr
verlassen
erinnerungen an die ermordung ihrer
geliebten einzigen tochter bestimmen bis
heute
[Musik]
eine tolle familie aber es fehlt eine
familie sie kann uns niemand geben auch
ehrlich auch männer kommt und jetzt
steht
und da ist das wort gerechtigkeit wo ist
die für uns wir kriegen bis zum
lebensende keiner mehr und da drin liegt
es war sein letzter wunsch das noch zu
erleben
und ich habe ihm versprochen dass ich
das tue
und ich habe sie ihr versprochen
wer hat heike rimbach ermordet es ist
ein versprechen und die hoffnung dass
der mörder von heike eines tages doch
noch gefunden
es tut mir nach wie vor leid dass dieser
sachverhalt nicht geklärt wurde ich
meine nicht mal dass ich dir nicht
geklärt habe darauf kommt es nicht an es
kommt nicht darauf an wer das verbrechen
klärt dass es geklärt wird und das ist
eigentlich
mein wunsch
[Musik]
deshalb will die polizei magdeburg auch
heute noch wissen wem ist am vormittag
des 28
august 1995 rund um die alte schäferei
in lütgenrode etwas ungewöhnliches
aufgefallen
wer kann angaben zu auffälligen personen
und fahrzeugbewegungen rund um den
tatort im zeitraum zwischen dem 27 und
28 august 1995 machen
[Musik]
darüber hinaus appellieren die polizei
und die familie rimbach an täter
mitwisser oder zeugen melden sie sich
erleichtern sie ihr gewissen denn jedes
neue detail jede information kann dazu
führen dass aus dem kot case heike
rimbach nach 26 jahren ein aufgeklärter
fall wird und die familie rimbach
endlich ihren frieden findet
[Musik]